lil wayne look close there  there's wheezy right there does he like  to say yes  throw up the deuces you know life's a  beach he's just playing in a special  celebrity watching  as well lil wayne look close  there's there's wheezy right there does  he like to say yes  throw up the deuces life's a beach he's  just playing in the sand right now  [Music]  experience courtside reinvented with  michelob ultra  tweet hashtag ultracourtside with  hashtag sweepstakes  for a chance to win tickets wheezy  checking this one out virtually  trying to cause an uproar three points  in that win against utah a couple of  nights ago went just one for three from  the field  he has seven here tonight wheezy  watching virtually  cheering on the lakers